just thank you to the organizers for
this invitation this is a very rare and
welcome opportunity for me basically my
presentation looks at the perspective of
three main up doors for us China and the
Philippines and the I guess the main
message is that we really have a rather
complex situation before us that so many
different levels if you look at the
domestic politics the national interests
and the regional security and other
concerns involved and there's no that
doesn't seem to be an easy way out for
the region as a whole in managing the
South China Sea conflicts and the
disputes now but there are there is a
need to identify priorities for for
conflict management and the solution so
essentially i have i think four themes
that I try to develop it's not a paper
ya know but I'd like to talk first about
self-fulfilling prophecies the three
actors US China and Philippines if you
look at the situation now compared to
five years ago we seem to have fallen
into self-fulfilling prophecies the
second is squander is facing each of
these actors if there is uncertainties
in the way ahead especially as the
domestic politics enter into the picture
and the fourth is defining priorities so
I try to be brief this is not as much a
product of research as we saw in the
earlier panel this morning as I guess
general observations from constant
looking at the events as they evolve in
the region and certainly a lot of
conferencing and communications to and
fro with other academics and other
experts on this so first one
self-fulfilling prophecies now I think I
think we understand that Chinese
assertiveness in the u.s. rebalance
policy in in Asia are both driven by
geopolitical interests so on the one
hand
part of the United States who have some
would call it military preponderance
some primacy so the interest in
sustaining us primacy on the one hand
versus China's demand for strategic
space some would call it hegemony it all
depends on the perspective really the
geopolitical interests also involved the
need for access to and control over
supply routes are zillions of navigation
weather for trade energy military
navigation and as a subtext also both US
and China are interested in a in
influence over shaping regional order or
shaping the regional security
architecture if you have to be more
specific on the other hand the
Philippines we are not a major power of
course we are not but we are a major
player in the sense that the country has
shown some capacity to impact on the
regional environment through its
interactions with these two big powers
and through our own claims in the South
China Sea what the Philippines needs is
access to resources security against
external threat and a rules-based order
that will guarantee both so in my
presentation I first look at the
emerging neither things I guessing from
the perspectives of US China and the
Philippines and to show how important
perceptions are and how important they
have been resulting in self-fulfilling
prophecies as I mentioned earlier some
would say security dilemmas is what we
find ourselves in the dominant Chinese
narrative it seems is that the US pivot
or the rebalance its all about
containing China's rise and that China's
assertive and coercive approach in the
South China Sea from the viewpoint of
the other players is really a response
to these efforts by the United States to
prevent China's where the growth in
influence and power so for China this is
simply unacceptable especially not in
its backyard but
increasingly sees in Southeast Asia as a
strategic backyard and therefore it has
proceeded in response to the rebalance
policy with construction of islands and
as we had seen earlier with various
ostensible purposes but including
obviously military purposes in mind and
this has invited direct intervention of
the United States now now that's a
Chinese narrative in a sense now what
compared to say even five years ago when
the United States took a neutral
position more neutral position and the
sovereignty disputes arguably it still
does now and I was very worried about
getting and trapped or entangled in the
contests of a maritime nature among
among these countries and now we see
enhanced your security arrangements and
tangible new commitments so its allies
and part either partners in the region
so for China one might say that this
this is a self-fulfilling prophecy
China's actions have drawn not only the
United States but even countries like
Japan other allies and the attention of
the international community is very much
on how China behaves what china says and
does with the guides to this issue by in
in a way by what i think is an
overreaction to the rebalance china has
produced precisely that outcome that it
prefers the list which is a strong US
presence and interest in this issue now
for the US its narrative in east asia is
that China's influence has grown there
are many narratives of course not but
one might say that the thinking the
perception that China's influence has
grown at the expense of the influence of
the United States and the rebalance
therefore is intended to prevent the
rise of a peer competitor in other words
to defend us pray
see in what China increasingly planes as
it's a sphere of influence now and the
self-fulfilling prophecy here it is that
China has really dug in it has abandoned
much of the self restraint that it used
to exercise in the past abandoning the
heightened by policy after and shopping
it is now competing with the u.s. openly
for the loyalty of smaller countries in
the region and is certainly showing a
lot of muscle meanwhile for the
Philippines hoping to benefit from the
Convention on the law of the sea to
extend its maritime rights over
resources we have challenged China
diplomatically and then legally but in
the meantime we have lost major fishing
grounds due to chinese croatian we find
our hands tied in terms of preventing
encroachments on it's easy because we
have filed a legal case you are awaiting
the outcome in the meantime the
government rightly or wrongly has taken
a policy of not doing anything to
prevent these things from happening not
encouraging our fishermen to go stopping
the oil exploration activities and in a
sense it has put pretty much everything
in this legal basket and there is also
some debate in the country over the
wisdom of that and at the same time it
has to call in its allies after all and
and rather while the Philippines tries
to take a moral high ground by pursuing
the legal case and saying that you know
it's not it's not going to be a might is
right situation but right makes might
it's also in a position where it is
helpless without the support of the
United States and that's about might
rather than right so these are some of
the issues that are that confront
Philippines but nonetheless the
situation now is one where in in some
sense or all three parties China the
United States and the Philippines
are in are confronted with a situation
that is not to their liking China is
confronted with a more robust and direct
us pressure us asked to contend with a
new status quo after the island
construction activities of China that
can of course in the view of many cannot
be reversed this greater Chinese
military presence in the area now that's
the new reality that the actors have to
contend with and the Philippines are
still hoping for a favorable ruling for
the arbitration may find that in the
long run the enjoyment of this fishing
and energy exploration rights may not
come quickly in the short term because
of issues of how to enforce okay so one
might say also that the geopolitical
context has turned the arbitration
process into what may have might have
been a relatively simple case of
determining determining maritime
entitlements into a geopolitical contest
and also a moral debate on the role of
big powers and small powers in
establishing a rules-based regional
order now quandary is all three pipe
this face quandaries in the management
of relations and how to promote their
respective interests now for instance in
the United States it needs to defensive
its its primacy to defend its primacy
with less resources a pan so adjustment
sinister in its strategy involving
burden sharing with allies linking
spokes instead of a simple hub and
spokes approach these are also
reflections of the the lack of resources
to put behind the huge effort required
no us has to balance between sustaining
the credibility of its system of
alliances but at the same time to avoid
unwanted entanglements based on the most
recent developments why one might say
that Washington has done a lot to shore
up its credibility but over the long
term
the issues of sustainability and
successful leadership of the effort to
push back against China is there would
still be in question so there are no
easy answers on how to deal with China
because China is not just an emerging
peer competitor but on certain important
issues remains an important partner and
managing other issues like Korean
Peninsula and so on if military
deterrence would be the main I guess
role of the United States or the main
position in the South China Sea or the
most prominent role then there are bound
to be trade-offs in the other
cooperative dimensions of its
relationship with China that it is still
trying to to pursue China has its own
boundaries and it is clearly a
dissatisfied power but one that is not
quite ready capability wise to confront
the United States the xi jinping
government has a very ambitious vision
on the China dream rejuvenation and but
this will have to be attained I made
first of all and economic slowdown
happening in the country now and second
is rising distrust of China's intentions
among its immediate neighbors currently
China's neighbourhood policy
particularly with reference to the South
China Seas full of contradictions there
are many elements of it but they are
poorly articulated there are and it's
difficult for countries to be persuaded
because they are simply too many
contradictions I suppose to just to keep
it simple the 21st century my time Silk
Road for example I wants to embark on
major infrastructure development
programs working with other countries in
Southeast Asia to develop ports and
railways whatever they need for to
enhance connectivity of the economies
which is good which is good which is
welcomed by many countries but while it
does that it challenges territorial
integrity it you know moves too quickly
and too
in a way forcefully with respect to
competing maritime interests of women
countries like Malaysia Indonesia it's
not just the Philippines and Vietnam
these days just a second I lost me okay
cue cards so my time Silk Road China
also has adopted a dual-track policy
towards ASEAN on the South China Sea one
track says that it still prefers you
know negotiations friendly consultations
to address the sovereignty disputes with
a with affected as in states and the
second track is that it is prepared to
deal with ASEAN to discuss regional
stability to preserve regional stability
now there is hardly a clear demarcation
between this two and in the current the
current situation so how to pursue this
duo trap is really still a problem there
are still efforts to pursue the to
implement the Declaration of Conda and
to negotiate a code of conduct but the
in my sense we've been talking about the
code of conduct for many years the
situation of island construction
militarization that's taking place now
is what a code of conduct was supposed
to be preventing in the first place now
so are we still on the right track are
we still talking about an essay and
China mechanism for conflict prevention
or should we be involved in more and
more players since the issue has really
become much bigger in many ways ok it
seems that also their efforts by China
to divide and undermine a science role
in all of this so that's another source
of concern and yeah ok so for the
Philippines looking at the Philippines
what are the quandary is that we we have
night the Philippines is caught in a
bind on whether to be guided by
pragmatism in its approach towards China
or principle
I didn't even know there was such a word
principal issam they taking a principal
at Stan no especially in light of
China's more muscular behavior in the
South China Sea this is a continuing
debate we have this very much faith in
the legal processes we are you know
hopefully nearing an outcome that will
be more favorable to the Philippines and
yet there are become China is you know
number one or number two biggest trading
partner of the Philippines it's not a
major investor it's a fastest rising
source of tourists which is an important
industry for the country so there will
always be this forces you know business
sectors who who would prefer and more
normal relationship with China
regardless of the disputes so even if we
do get a favorable legal outcome the
long term preference is still for a good
relationship with China and that
continues to put pressure on the
leadership and believe Philippines has
to rely on the military alliance with
the United States but even if the
Philippines the credibility are there
are questions about the sustainability
of US policy well for various reasons
one is their perception of a low level
of material support in the past the
insistence of neutrality which was such
a long conversation between the US are
the efforts of past Philippine
government's to persuade the u.s. to
include the South Island's claimed
islands in the scope of the mutual
defense treaty had been going on since
the 60s so it was a really a constant
conversation and only in the last few
years are we I guess I the press the
groups that prefer this kind of a strong
policy we are we are getting close to to
that situation the loss of Scarborough
Shoal in the Philippines and the
involvement of the u.s. in the supposed
negotiations for a mute while or a
simultaneous pull out also showed in a
way show the witness
also of the us it became part of this
process it was not when the outcome of
course was very unfavorable for the
Philippines so that also raised some
questions on what role should the u.s.
be paying should the u.s. be allowed to
get between Philippines and China as far
as these kinds of situations go another
quandary said the Philippines has staked
its claim to marine resources at a
political cause of great political cost
and over the long run if the interest is
access to resources as we mentioned and
and a peaceful and stable Southeast
Asian region that there is much that
will need to be done cooperatively and
inclusively rather than exclusively also
the rivalry the geopolitical contest
basically the power rivalry between
China and the US can threaten to overlay
the this other you know smaller goals
and concerns of the country raising
questions about whether core interest of
the country will ultimately be be served
so um not going to uncertainties there
are a number of uncertainties that make
it more difficult to deal with this
quandary so make it difficult to
mitigate the impact of the earlier
described you know self-fulfilling
prophecies as you said you have a new
status quo of China's a Chinese military
presence in the area more more involved
United States and possibly unenforceable
maritime rights and claims of the
Philippines and maybe other countries
and while we need to go around those
that situation domestic politics
introduces considerable uncertainty on
the part of the u.s. going forward from
whoever me twins in the US elections in
November will be rebalance policy
persist particularly recent initiatives
to enhance the capability of smaller
regional States for maritime domain
awareness and greater visibility of the
US and as a deterrent to further Chinese
actions so it's not going to stay in
with the next government in the case of
the Philippines maybe even more so
whoever becomes the next president of
the Philippines with the new government
stay the course with respect to both
seeing the arbitration process through
to the end expect this is an especially
important question if China forcefully
rejects the arbitration ruling will the
next president of the Philippines also
persist in developing a more robust
security partnership with the US and
Japan and other allies now in China
there are some internal developments
also that are really becoming quite
interesting and for those of course in
international relations who watch the
the situation with it's difficult to
make an assessment of whether they will
have an impact on foreign policy in the
short run but well evidence that Chinese
leader Xi Jinping's beginning to
encounter resistance to his disciplining
you know anti-corruption moves being
accused of engaging in some purging in
the process will say for instance some
internal debates within China about
domestic as well as foreign policy
Direction create opportunities for for
policy adjustments may be mending ties
with neighbors that have been afraid of
late by heavy handedness of the South
China Sea and the East China Sea issue
or will internal political struggles
result in more pressure on you know by
in place pressure by one faction or
another to show off nationalist
credentials now and to rally the Chinese
people over over this disputed areas so
relative to this it's really how China
reacts to the arbitration outcome that
will be critical to regional building
regional order building efforts of the
countries at this time and the
uncertainties which has them from the
domestic political situations are a big
question mark as well so um for
solutions there are none really that
that are easy to to articulate or
envision what the question is I think
how to deter China's unilateral is
exceptional is you know coercive and
spicy ASEAN is concerned divisive
behavior or how to get China to play by
the same rules as everyone else it's a
big question but there's also the
question of how to agree on the rules in
the first place we have been as I
mentioned we'll be talking about the
code of conduct we have been talking
about Q's agreement and code of
unintended or unplanned encounters see
extending this to involve the law
enforcement authorities the Coast Guard
so a lot of proposals have been thrown
the table a lot of I guess rule oriented
proposals I have still to be negotiated
and agreed upon another question is how
to be in the parties to the table to
harmonize their efforts at problem
solving strategic distrust i think is a
very important obstacle at the point
where we find ourselves in no matter how
on the part of the philippines for
instance no matter how we would like to
be pragmatic practical we don't trust
the other side so how to overcome that
how to avoid polarization between the
two major powers it's also important so
the questions relevant to that would be
but is there a role for middle powers
what about the other players who are not
claimants who are not outside of the US
and China South Korea Australia Canada
ASEAN collectively Indonesia Europe even
and now we are talking more and more
about mini laterals multilateralism
broadly defined doesn't seem to have
work bilateral listen we just don't have
the basic trust needed to take it on so
what other options are we ready to
creatively explore so I'm being bad I'm
basing questions at the end of the
presentation rather than providing
answers thank you